querque hungry yeah I could totally do
some salad good to see this new
generation of drunk shamers being more
calorie conscious yeah I could totally
do some salad one of those guys blows a
hot load of ranch on him
shocking that a stay-at-home mom found
time and her grueling schedule to set
this up is part of this prank living in
that narrow wood panelled popcorn
ceiling hellhole she left the door ajar
so will actually come home excited
thinking his family was murdered
[Music]
classic epic pwnage this is the single
saddest moment silly-string has ever
been involved in he's not mad he's just
disappointed with his entire life he
find yourself getting scratchers and
vitaminwater at the quick Phil in
Syracuse be on the lookout
[Music]
hey Josh look at this huge moth that I
found oh there goes
is that cool yeah 100% chance that moth
ends up on the hotdog rollers it's never
too late to let someone know how you
feel about them he were so close to
being out of that relationship every
girl's fantasy a prank posle who's ready
for the prank of the week and the war
between North and South Korea is back on
you really want to freak her out do with
a mouthful of Nesquik well she won't be
the last girl tricked into drinkin man
milk against her will
hashtag me 2%
you